[Music]
the finder is the first of the five
stories found in ursula kayla green's
fifth earth sea book tales from earthsea
and it tells us the backstory of roke
and of magic and of earth sea itself its
political disintegration
into
not quite anarchy but a time a very dark
time of slavery and war lords and
battles between wizards and
people turning against the magic users
who are actually doing good like the
village sorcerers and witches and
central to the turning point of the
story is going to be what happens on the
isle of roke long familiar to all of us
earth sea readers from the first four
novels this is the back story about how
rogue came to be
rogue and what we find is
originally
it's a very different kind of place and
it all of this happens largely through
the eyes of medra or otter later on
he'll be called turn and he goes by
other names as well in different places
and
we
get gradually introduced to rock in part
by seeing
the reflections of what we could call
the the actions and plans
early on of rock
manifested in the hand and before that
we get to see that otter runs into
things that are kind of like the hand
but not quite the same otter is a boy on
hovnor who was born with some magical
ability
and
otter is taught more than just the song
of creation by this this wise woman a
crafty person right and she knew his
gift she she and some men and women like
her people of no fame some of
questionable reputation had and all some
degree that gift and they shared in
secret what lore and craft they had now
why this is this is something that's
going to get us to the the grand idea of
the pattern or the equilibrium in a bit
a gift untaught is a ship unguided they
said to otter and they taught him all
they knew
it wasn't much but there were some
beginnings of the great arts in it and
though he felt uneasy at deceiving his
parents he couldn't resist this
knowledge and the kindness and praise of
his poor teachers it will do you no harm
if you never use it for harm they told
them and that was easy
for him to promise
them
and then later he runs into a man who's
the changer and he teaches otter some
illusion and then he teaches him the
great spell of changing and he's told
that if he learns the changer's great
spell he would never use it but to save
a life his own or another's and so otter
is is being introduced not just to
the art of magic
but also to the need to keep it secret
and also to the fact that it's not just
supposed to be used for any ends
whatsoever like the great wizards do
uh gain rivalry those sorts of things
and even when he's taken prisoner
by
lawson and his men who are going to use
them the hound says
we crafty people need to stick together
so even the hound who's caught up in
this can recognize that there's there's
some need to have solidarity you could
say
later on he's going to encounter the
you could call it the first fingers of
the hand
that he can
run into
so this is after he escapes from
the wizard gaelic and takes anyab as far
as she can go before she dies and then
comes to her her village
and they tell him
there's people all over these parts and
maybe beyond who think as you said that
nobody can be wise alone
so these people try to hold to each
other and that's why we're called the
hand or the women of the hand though
we're not women only but it serves us to
call ourselves women for the grateful
don't look for women to work together or
to have thoughts about such things as
rule or misrule or have any powers
calling themselves women in a world that
is male dominated allows them to
disguise themselves and then they bring
up the idea about morid's isle
a place where the women of the hand have
kept the old arts and they teach them
not keeping them a secret each to
himself as the wizards do
and mead says maybe with such teaching
you could teach the wizards a lesson and
io says maybe you can find that island
otter looked from one to the other
clearly they had told him their own
greatest secret
and their hope
more exile he said that would be only
what the women of the hand call it
keeping its meaning from the wizards and
the pirates to them it would no doubt
bear some other name
and so
over the next several years that is what
otter or medra is looking for calling
himself by many names as he sails the
islands of earthsea actually getting to
study with a mage who he becomes
apprenticed to hydrate in pandora
and takes over as a
mage for a short amount of time and then
goes sailing again looking for this
aisle
and he will find it
because of shipwreck
they get close to rock and
the ship is turned on its side he
changes himself into a sea bird flies
off and when he lands on the island he's
transformed back into his own
human form so this is really
quite something right
there's a great description here
to it he flew and on it he landed it and
as he touched the earth he was a man
again he stood there for a while
bewildered seemed to him it was not by
his own act or decision he had taken his
own form but that in touching this
ground this hill he had become himself a
magic greater than his own
prevailed here
he looked around cautious and wary
all across the hill sparkweed was in
flowers long petals blazing yellow in
the glass and the grass
children of hovnor knew that flower
and he goes down
then he saw
people they stood among the tall grasses
among the
flame shaped flowers nodding in the wind
of morning then they were all gone
and he stood alone on the hill shaking
and wondering i have seen the kings and
queens of earth sea and they are only
the grass that grows on this hill so he
knows this is a special place he walks
into town starts chatting to people and
now they want to know who is this guy
and what's he doing and they ask him how
did you actually
come here
and he says i was born in havnor trained
as a shipwright and sorcerer i was on a
ship bound from geeth to old port i was
spared alone from drowning last night
when a witch wins struck and then they
say how did you come here as a bird a
turn is this roque island you changed
yourself he nodded whom do you serve
this is a key question for them
she had a keen hard face with long black
brows i have no master what was your
errand in oport in hovner years ago i
was in servitude those who freed me told
me about a place where there are no
masters and the rule of sarriad is
remembered and the arts are honored i
have been looking for that place that
island seven years
who told you about it the women of the
hand
anyone can make a fist and show a palm
said the tall woman pleasantly but not
everybody can fly to rope or swim or
sail or come in any way so we must ask
what brought you here
and here we
find out more about medra's own mindset
chance
favoring long desire
not art not knowledge
i think i've come to the place i sought
but i don't know i think you may be the
people they told me of but i don't know
i think the trees i saw from the hill
hold some great mystery but i don't know
i only know that since i've set foot on
the hill i've been as i was when i was a
child and first heard the deed of
enlarge i am lost among
wonders
then they they
ask him again
if you stayed here what would you do
i can build boats or mend them and sail
them i can find above and underground i
can work weather if you have any need
from that and i'll learn the art for
many who will teach me
what do you want to learn they ask and
now here you would imagine he would say
well this kind of magic and this kind of
magic and this kind of magic that i
heard of that would be really great
what does he say instead
a moral and metaphysical question
something very very deep
medra felt he had been asked the
question on which the rest of his life
hung for good or evil
he started to speak and didn't speak and
finally spoke
i could not save one not one not the one
who saved me nothing i know could have
set her freeze talking about aniab who
saved him i know nothing if you know how
to be free i beg you
teach me
so this is what he's looking for not
just freedom to enjoy
but to understand what freedom is and
this leads to a long discourse that's
going to tell us about why rock is the
way it is they are all
prisoners on the isle where they are
safe and free at least for the time
being and now we come to the story of
the
invasion
30 years before the pirate lords of watt
hort had sent to fleet to conquer roque
not for its wealth which was little but
to break the power of its madrid which
was reputed to be great now why because
the hand and its madrid are promoting
freedom
from
slavery from domination from fear from
exploitation in other places
one of the wizards of roke had betrayed
the island to the crafty men of wathort
their own wizards right lowering its
spells of defense and warning once those
were breached the pirates took the
island not by wizardries but force and
fire their great ships filled twill bay
their hordes burned and looted their
slave takers carried off men boys young
women little children in the old they
slaughtered they fired every house and
field they came to
when they sailed away after a few days
they left no village standing the farm
stood in ruins or
desolate
so most of the islanders who had
survived were wise women and their
children who had hidden themselves in
the town or in the imminent grove which
will come too soon the men now on rock
were those spared children grown and a
few men now grown old there was no
government left but the women of the
hand for it was their spells that had
protected rogue so long and protected it
far more closely now they had little
trust in men
a man had betrayed them men had attacked
them it was men's ambitions they said
that it perverted all the arts to ends
of gain we do not deal with their
government's said tall veil in her mild
voice
so
this is
where they are now they are a
matriarchal society run by the women who
have magical power distrustful of the
ways of men rightly so since
you know the raiding and looking at the
rest of earth sea outside
we also learned that men and women of
the hand had joined together on rogue
100 or more years ago forming a league
of mages
proud and secure in their powers they'd
sought to teach others to band together
in secret against the war makers and
slave takers until they could rise
openly against them women had always
been leaders in the league said ember
and women in the guise of sav sellers
and net makers and such had gone from
rope to other lands among the inmosi
weaving a fine wide net of resistance
and that is what the network of the hand
was and still to some degree is so
it's not just magical power
that
roque represents it's
a
way of understanding the world and human
beings
and
morality a way that's in some respects
realistic and optimistic about the
prospects many people when they are
placed in conditions where they see that
the good don't prosper and the evil do
in fact you know hold power they get
cynical and say well there's nothing we
can do roque was a place that was using
magical power
to undo that to prepare a way for a
better
earthsea and they are attacked for that
the rest of the hand winds up being cut
off
by rogue's choice of isolation a choice
that is an easy choice to make given the
horrors and trauma inflicted upon them
so the rest of the hand is you know the
fingers you the connective tissues are
all allowed to sort of go their
own way
and that you know can can be kind of a
problem right
even now there were strands and knots of
that that net left
medra had come on one of those traces
first in anab village and followed them
since but they had not led them
not led him here
since the raid rogue island had isolated
itself wholly sealed itself inside
powerful spells of protection
woven and re-woven by the wise women of
the island and had no commerce with any
other people we can't save them ember
said we couldn't save ourselves is are
they drawing the wrong lesson from the
fact that they couldn't save themselves
at that time
what are they doing there they are
sharing with each other as
leguin remarks
what they had they shared in that it was
indeed morid's aisle nobody on roke
starved or went unhoused though nobody
had much more than they needed
hidden from the rest of the world not
only by sea and storm but their defenses
they worked and talked and sang the
songs the winter carol and the deed of
the young king and they had books the
chronicles of endless in the history of
the wise heroes from these precious
books the old men and women would read
aloud in a hall down by the wharf where
the fisher women made and mended their
nets there was a hearth there and they
would light the fire people came even
from farms across the island to hear the
histories red listening in silence
intent our souls are hungry ember said
there is a desire
for knowledge a desire for
meaning a desire for hearing about a
time that's not all
pillage
and butchery
and blind ambition and damage done
without attention to the pattern
governing the world they spend their
time teaching and learning rebuilding
there's also a beautiful side story here
about ember
and
you know taren now otter taran medra
falling in love in the imminent grove he
goes and you know the imminent grove are
trees whose roots go down to the very
bottom
of earth sea
he he asks amber to tell him what the
imminent grove was for when he'd asked
others they said ember can tell you she
refused his question not arrogantly but
definitely saying you can learn about
the grove only in
and from it
and he goes along she says i'll be going
to the grove after the long dance come
if you like there's some great
descriptions of it it seemed that from
roknoll the whole extent of the grove
could be seen yet if you walked in it
you did not always come out in the
fields again you walked on under the
trees in the inner grove they were all
of one kind which grew nowhere else yet
had no name in heartache but tree
in the old speech ember said each of
these trees
had its own name
implying that they are all like persons
you walked on and after a while you were
walking again among familiar trees
people in thrill told them it was best
not to go on too far since only by
returning as you went could you be sure
about coming out into the fields how far
does the forest go madre asked and ember
said as the mind goes
the leaves of the tree spoke she said in
the shadows could be read i am learning
to read them
and so he camps nearby
he doesn't know what ember wanted of him
he hoped she meant to teach him to
answer his questions about the grove but
she said nothing and he was shy and
cautious fearing to intrude upon her
solitude the second day he was there he
told her to come with her and let her
very far let him very far into the wood
they walked for hours in silence in the
summer midday the woods were silent no
birds saying the leaves did not stir the
aisles of the trees were endlessly
different and all the same he did not
know when they turned back but he knew
they'd walk farther than the shores of
rock
and they spend time together
over and over
with that and eventually they fall in
love
they become a
couple and he says
they're eating peaches if i told you my
name my true name i i tell you mine she
said if that's how we should begin
they began however with the peaches they
were both shy when medra took her his
hand shook in ember whose name was ella
hall turned away scowling then she
touched his hand very lightly and it
goes on from there they become intimate
they become
a couple and they will become great
supports to
each other
their their friendship develops
the question that they will engage with
that
they will uh not just have like a debate
about but actually work out with each
other
is what should happen now
and this is a
key issue
he tells the story of the minds of
sommery the willard gaelic and aniab the
slave to veil and ember when he was done
veil was silent a long time and then
said that's what you meant when you
first came here i could not save the one
who saved me and you asked me what could
you tell that would make me trust you
um here we go she gave me freedom he
said and i still feel that all i do is
done through her and for her not not for
her we can do nothing for the dead but
ember says for us who for us who live in
hiding neither killed nor killing the
dead are dead the great and mighty go
their way unchecked all the hope left in
the world is of the people of no account
and then the question comes up must we
hide
forever
is this the course that we have to
pursue number says spoken like a man
and there is a good reason why they
should hide she says yes we must hide in
forever if need be there's nothing left
but being killed and killing beyond
these shores
madras says but you can't hide true
power not for long it dies in hiding
unshared and vale says magic won't die
on rock on rope all spells are strong
you've walked under the trees our job
must be to keep that strength hide it
yes hoard it as a young dragon hoards up
his fire and share it but only here pass
it on one to the next where it's safe
and where the great robbers and killers
would at least look for it since no one
here is of any account and one day the
dragon will come into its strength if it
takes a thousand years and then here's
the central problem but outside rock
medra said there are common people who
slave and starve and die in misery
must they do so for a thousand years
with no
hope
and here's where we have the question of
of the pattern uh the the equilibrium as
as they come to call it right should
they remain hidden at the center of
magic where the pattern will hold the
pattern is strong but everywhere outside
is chaos and exploitation and domination
and destruction and fear
and
here's what embers says the true art
prevails over the false the pattern will
hold that i know but our lives are short
and the pattern's very long
if only rogue was what it
what if if only roke was now what it
once was if we had more people of the
true art gathering here teaching and
learning as well as preserving
and uh madras says the solution lies in
secrecy but so does the
problem
and then
coming out of out of uh
not medra but ember comes another
suggestion
a school
where the wise might come to learn from
one another to study the pattern the
grove would shelter us and then they
talked into long winter and others
talked with them slowly their talk
turned from vision to intention from
longing to planning vale was always
cautious warning of dangers white-haired
dune was so eager ember said he wanted
to start teaching sorcery to every child
and twill once ember had come to believe
that rogue's freedom lay in offering
others freedom that's a very key thing
there
then she set her whole mind on how the
women of the hand might grow strong
again
and they realize that they need to
formulate their art they need to figure
out what their art actually is now
that's a key insight though that we
should go back to their freedom is not
something that can be hoarded up
isolated from the rest of the world
their freedom is in teaching
others freedom which will be a dangerous
thing to do it will place them at risk
it will not always succeed it will often
fail
but it's still something that holds out
a greater prospect and can extend
this pattern and restore it within
earthsea and that is
indeed what rogue
in its its you know full sense
is refounded to do
you